[Music]  why'd you say we're gonna be here for  you said that I'd be back for our  graduation you should stand our mountain  house I thought you guys are selling I  just have to leave for a bit on Sundays  during open houses it's good to see some  new faces  you must be Logan everybody knows  everybody in these small towns huh so  sorry for what happened to your husband  I lost my husband a few years back  chef's it's like it moves in it never  leaves  Sam searched the entire house there's no  one here we had an open house here a few  days ago maybe someone found a spare key  laying around her gonna do something  stayed probably just some kids trying to  scare the newcomers didn't feel like  kids who's that  Hey Hey something is clearly going on  hello is anyone there  that's always nice to know you have  someone nearby the quiet out here can  get real loud  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]